of Latvia Eagles Levitt president Levitz
we are honored that you will address the
house of European democracy shortly
before the first anniversary of the
Russian invasion of Ukraine since the
24th of February 2022 the day Putin's
regime launched an illegal and brutal
attack on Sovereign Ukraine Latvia has
led on shaping EU policy and has
demonstrated unwavering support for
Ukraine's cause and solidarity with
Ukrainian people there is no doubt that
the world has changed after
356 days of War on our continent and
throughout that change I am glad that
the European Union can count on members
like Latvia and Latvia can count on the
European Union too we know that together
the European Union will build a real
security and defense Union
and president your country knows as you
also know what it means to be under
political pressure from an oppressive
authoritarian regime our European Union
must remain the guarantee that the past
can never again be the future the last
generation broke down walls and tore
open curtains in the name of Liberty and
democracy that is Europe's Legacy and
one that it is now up to us to preserve
Latvia is a symbol of Hope of
transformation and of the enduring proof
in a people and a nation's ability to
overcome the odds to break free from
authoritarianism and join a union based
on shared values of Justice freedom and
democracy European Union must prevail
and unity must Prevail because it is
only together that Europe can rise to
meet the challenges of our time
president Levitz the floor is yours
foreign
[Applause]
honorable honorable president of the
European Parliament
honorable members of the European
Parliament
first of all in the name of the people
of Latvia I'd like to express my deepest
condolences to the friends and families
of those tragically perished in the
recent earthquakes in turkey and Syria
Europe it is only right that a European
Union is solid there it shows solidarity
in this situation ladies and gentlemen
the European Parliament is a political
heart of Europe
it is here that the diverse interests
thoughts and opinions of the citizens of
European Union meet
it is here that the public
opinion of the 450 million of the
European citizens is shaped
Europe has to show it has to make sure
that its economic intellectual and
cultural potential is used so that all
450 million of us
can shape and live our lives according
to our values and so that we could
achieve our goals
yes
now
this
is firstly linked to a person's
nationality Society culture and language
they have the responsibility of their
democracy and solidarity
thank you
first and foremost policies come from
the state nevertheless citizens of the
European Union
have more than that being the citizen of
the European Union means not only
thinking about your country but also the
European Union
it's a twofold duty
that also therefore means that European
citizens need to have a focus on the
European Union as a whole not only on
their country but the European Union as
a whole
it is up to all of us
European citizens and also political
Representatives
to
move from a national
point of view to looking at things at us
in a supranational Mala manner ladies
and gentlemen this is in German
this is something we still need to work
on
after the fall of the Soviet Union
Europe grew together
artificial borders were done away with
on a step-by-step basis but the borders
of our consciousness of our awareness of
a European Society these borders still
exist
European history
has
all too for too long been seen as the
history of just Western Europe and this
provincialism when it comes to looking
at Europe as a whole
prevents us from achieving our goals
the full history of Europe is a history
in which all European nations
can recognize themselves and their
historical experience
Europe today has no Center and no
periphery
Europe
is in Riga Paris Warsaw Berlin Bucharest
and Brussels all these places have a
role in shaping Europe
in Allen education London in Allen
education in all European countries and
All European capitals also in Oslo
Berlin London and also in Kiev
[Applause]
honorable members
we need a common understanding of
European history where there is a place
was a historical experience of All
European nations
we need to consolidate a common point of
view
from which the whole of Europe from
north to south from east to west can be
seen
and from which the world and Europe's
place in it is clear so that we can
Define that Europe wants to achieve
globally
over 20 years ago the German political
philosopher Jurgen habermas identified
the lack of a common European public
opinion erropez
as one of the European Union's biggest
problem
since then I I believe that things have
have somewhat improved
the common European public opinion has
acquired greater significance in the
minds of citizens
crisis such as coveted 19 pandemic and
Russia's aggression towards Ukraine have
also contributed to our common
consciousness of us as Europeans
this is a basis of your of Europe
for the ability to act
the European Parliament is a unique
democratically legitimized European
forum
I therefore call on you honorable
members to play a more active role in
shaping the common European public
opinion
this that does not mean merely advancing
National Economic or other interests in
a fierce battle for compromise
in the Parliamentary debates and
decisions you need to achieve a European
Vision that is qualitatively more
advanced than just agreeing on a price
use Solutions must be truly European
such Solutions must equally incorporate
the national and historical experiences
and actual Equitable interests of all
member states
they must synthesize them into a new
quality
that is that European citizens expect
from you
to represent the whole European union we
need to understand its member states
better
and for example only a very small number
of you members of the European
Parliament have ever been in Latvia
let me therefore today encourage you to
visit Latvia and get to know us better
[Applause]
when thinking about European Solutions
we need to be clear about the European
foundations
our shared values our common European
legal system
precisely that that
distinguished the European Union from
all other International organizations
from all other International platforms
our values and legal system make Europe
and our common way of life European way
of life attractive for us and attractive
for others
values such as democracy the rule of law
and fundamental human rights
their source of the strengths of the
European Union
the member states of the European Union
are in principle stable Consolidated
democracies
however we Face serious challenges
the most obvious challenge
is a desire to limit the rule of law on
the basis of populist arguments about
the will of the people
[Applause]
a modern constitutional democracy is
based on a carefully balanced system
on the one hand you have a
democratically legitimized parliaments
and governments
on the other an independent
professionally legitimized judiciary
the Democratic process itself three
elections and political freedoms the
very core of the European Union's
political identity can only be
guaranteed by such a system of checks
and balances
I say this is my 24 years of experience
as judge at the European Court of Human
Rights and as a court of justice of the
European Union
the upsetting of this balance with the
proponents of constitutional populism as
seeking to achieve May ultimately lead
to the weakening or even the complete
loss of democracy itself
[Applause]
Europe is united in diversity
member states are diverse initials of
national identity officials of culture
language Traditions social fear and so
it should remain
here Europe must not interfere here
diversity is Europe's strength strength
however the principles of rule of law
must be the same everywhere
here diversity is permissible only in
the concrete manifestations of these
principles
the Europeans legal system is based on
Mutual Trust that the same principles
apply in all member states in the same
way without exceptions
if there is a problem is rule of law is
what in one member state it affects the
entire
European Union
in some cases these populist Tendencies
have already led to disputes that are
now difficult to unravel in a purely
legal way
in order to avoid an impasse here we
could find a political solution that
would cut this Guardian not
this would give the involved parties an
opportunity to start afresh
but in any case the rule of law in
Europe must not be weakened
honorable members
democracy and rule of law were under
threat
not only from within
today it is also threatened by Russia's
aggressive ideology which is behind
their attack on Ukraine a sovereign
Democratic European country
[Applause]
authoritarian Russian regime has gone
back 200 years in its thinking
it has regressed to the imperialist
colonialists and the racist ideology of
the 19th century
as a German example shows renouncing an
aggressive toxic ideology
requires a huge Collective effort
fergangenheit's
and it takes a long time
but it can be done
until Russian Society evaluates
overcomes condemns and clearly renounces
this ideology we have to reckon with
Russia as an aggressive state
let's say romantic Notions
of the broad Russian Soul remain to the
lovers of literature
this cannot be a light body for
politicians who are responsible for
Europe's security for Europe's future
we must also acknowledge enormous
mistake and naivety of moving
purposefully towards dependence of
Russian energy resources
and she also it would be also good to
reflect on how such a mistake was even
possible despite our warnings
certainly they put in first air in think
tanks and policy making circles Shadow
at all as did business interests
but in future Europe and the West as a
whole must not longer make such
strategic mistakes
therefore they need to be realistic
about Russia
the effective strategy towards Russia
aggressive Russia is deterrence through
credible defense capacities in all areas
if we do not want to betray the values
on which the European Union is founded
and if you do not want to lose our
credibility in the eyes of the future of
the generations then Europe must be on
the right side of the history
that means on the side of Ukraine
this war must an end with a victory of
Ukraine Russia started the war Russia
must end it now and withdraw from
Ukraine
the European Union and its member states
have provided significant support to
Ukraine
and I am proud that Latvia is currently
among the top providers of Aid to
Ukraine in terms of GDP per capita
not only is the government but also the
local authorities in the vast number of
individuals sent what help they can
certainly what the Ukraine needs most
urgently now is military equipment
equipment is weapons to win the war
but it also needs Justice and it needs a
future in Europe
in fact Ukraine needs we all need
search some words about law and justice
the charter of the United Nations
prohibits aggressive War
without this prohibition The Vault would
fall back into belligerent Anarchy
therefore the waging of a war of
aggression against another sovereign
state is the gravest possible crime in
modern international law
for the first time since the second
world war they are experiencing a vote
of aggression in Europe
international law most must therefore
respond
there must be a special tribunal to try
this crime of aggression
this is not only necessary for the sake
of Justice or Ukraine
it is necessary in order not to
undermine the standard of international
law
that has been achieved since the Second
World War
to make it absolutely clear that the
waging of a war of aggression is a crime
and thus responsible will be brought to
Justice
none of us wants to live in a world
where aggressive War would be an arm
however
however at the moment neither the
international criminal court nor any
other International mechanism can
exercise jurisdiction over this crime of
aggression
therefore it is necessary to create a
special tribunal to try Russia's
aggression against Ukraine
[Applause]
this has already been done in the cases
of Yugoslavia Rwanda Cambodia Liberia
Syria Sierra Leone and other cases each
case has been different
but however the International Community
has been creative and has found a way to
set up such tribunals
this is also more necessary in case of
Russia because as I said we are talking
about the most serious International
crime
in any case legally it is possible
all that is needed is political will
that where was one of the first
countries to encourage the creation of
such a tribunal last year shortly after
the outbreak of the war
now this proposal has already received
quite broad support
I was particularly like to thank you
honorable members for your resolution of
the 90s of January 19th of January this
year where you express your Firm support
for the creation of such a tribunal by
an overwhelming majority I think 470
against 19. it's clear bottom
I say you Ukraine Summit on the 3rd of
February the president of the commission
Ursula Van Der Lyon announced that the
European Union would establish an
international center for the prosecution
of the crime of aggression in Ukraine
which would begin to collect evidence
this is already the first practical step
towards the creation of such a Tribunal
the further political and legal roadmap
and details remained worked out
in any case Europe must be consistent
and ensure that this crime of aggression
can be tried in an international Court
the use of Frozen Russian assets for the
Reconstruction of Ukraine must also be
ensured
this applies not only to the assets of
the oligarchs close to the regime but in
particular to the assets of the Central
Bank of Russia
the U.S Canada and United Kingdom
have already done some preliminary work
here
again
other complicated it is legally possible
what is needed is political will
and I am confident that the European
Union will find this political will
in conclusion Madam president
last Thursday you rightly said to
president zielinski here in the European
Parliament
Ukraine is Europe
and your nation's future is in the
European Union
[Applause]
of course we see how difficult this path
will be for Ukraine
but we also see the determination and
courage of the ukrainians
for us it is much much less demanding
to be courageous
you have to make make the right decision
this is a historical decision that we
might have only one chance to make
the Ukrainian people have decided
now it is our turn
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much dear colleagues
before
we start the votes it is my sad duty to
inform you
of the death yesterday Monday of Jose
Maria Robles
who was president of the European
Parliament from 1997 to 1999 and who was
an eminent member of this house for 15
years
he served in many capacities during his
parliamentary terms and was a reporter
for a number of institutional reforms he
will be remembered for having ensured
that Parliament was directly